WITHIN PLAY FOR DEMOCRATS TO
MAINTAIN OR MAKE IT MORE
CERTAIN.
HARRY ENTEN, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>> THANK YOU, SIR.
>>> RIGHT NOW, ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT IS GOING ON RIGHT
UNDER YOUR NOSE.
REDISTRICTING THAT COULD DECIDE
THE FATE OF OUR POLITICS FOR THE
NEXT DECADE.
JOHN AVLON HAS A REALITY CHECK.
>> THERE ARE DIFFERENT FRONTS IN
THE WAR ON DEMOCRACY.
THERE IS THE GEOPOLITICAL FRONT,
WITH AUTOCRACIES CHALLENGING
DEMOCRACY AND THE BAD GUYS ARE
WINNING THERE.
THERE IS THE DISINFORMATION
FRONT AND THE DIGITAL REALM,
ERODING OUR ABILITY TO REASON
TOGETHER WITH ALGORITHMS THAT
ELEVATE EXTREMISM, AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES OVER ACTUAL
FACTS.
THEN THE EXTREME EXAMPLE OF
DEFENDING OUR DEMOCRACY, FROM
THE COUP ATTEMPT DONALD TRUMP
TRIED WITH THE BIG LIE THAT LED
TO THE ATTACK ON OUR CAPITOL.
THEN THERE IS THE MORE SUBROSA
STRUCTURAL STUFF, THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT ATTEMPT TO RIG
THE SYSTEM FOR PARTISAN GAIN,
AIMING TO UNDERCUT MAJORITY RULE
AND REAL REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S WHAT'S QUIETLY GOING ON
IN STATE CAPITOLS ACROSS THE
NATION.
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A ONCE IN
A DECADE REDISTRICTING AT THE
STATE LEVEL, WHICH DETERMINES
THE BASELINE OF CONGRESS FOR
NEXT DECADE.
WAIT, YOU SAY, THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS ARE A YEAR AWAY.
WELL, BLESS YOUR HEART, AS THEY
SAY IN THE SOUTH.
PROFESSIONAL PARTISANS ARE BUSY
TRYING TO PREDETERMINE
CONGRESSIONAL ELECTION OUTCOMES.
ALMOST AS IF THEY WERE TRYING TO
REDUCE FAITH IN DEMOCRACY.
GET THIS, ACCORDING TO THE COOK
POLITICAL REPORT, THE NUMBER OF
SWING SEATS IN CONGRESS FALL
FROM 164 IN 1997 TO JUST 72 IN
2016.
IT IS ABOUT TO GET MUCH, MUCH
WORSE.
ACCORDING TO THE NEW YORK TIMES
ANALYSIS, 12 STATES THAT HAVE
COMPLETED THE MAP PROCESS,
REPUBLICANS ADDED A NET FIVE NEW
SEATS THEY CAN SAFELY HOLD.
REPUBLICANS ARE DOWN ONE.
AND REPUBLICANS ONLY NEED TO
FLIP FIVE SEATS TO REGAIN
CONTROL OF CONGRESS.
TAKE A LOOK AT NORTH CAROLINA,
THE STATE IS VIRTUALLY EVEN IN
PARTY REGISTRATION.
REPUBLICAN STATE LEGISLATURE
JUST PASSED MAPS GIVING THEM A
10-4 SEAT CONGRESSIONAL
ADVANTAGE.
LOOK AT THE MAPS, YOU THINK THE
STATE GREW MORE WHITE AND RURAL,
WHICH MEANS MORE REPUBLICAN.
THAT'S DESPITE A CENSUS SHOWING
NORTH CAROLINA GREW MORE DIVERSE
AND LESS WHITE OVER THE PAST
DECADE.
THAT'S THE RIGGED SYSTEM OF
REDISTRICTING IN ACTION.
THAT'S THE STORY NATIONALLY.
AMERICA IS MORE DIVERSE AND MORE
URBAN, REPUBLICANS ARE CARVING
UP THE DISTRICTS TO INCREASE
THEIR HOLD ON POWER.
TAKE A LOOK AT TEXAS, WHICH
GAINED TWO SEATS DUE TO MASSIVE
GROWTH.
95% ATTRIBUTED TO PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
TRUMP WON 52% OF THE VOTE, THE
REPUBLICANS CONTROL 66% OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS.
THE NUMBER OF GOP DOMINATED
DISTRICTS FROM 22 TO 2.
BLACK DISTRICTS, FROM 1 TO 9.
LOOK AT OHIO, FOR SOME REALLY
LOPSIDED PARTISAN ABSURDITY.
BUCKEYE REPUBLICANS PROPOSED
MAPS THAT WOULD GIVE THEM A 13-2
MAJORITY DESPITE REPUBLICAN
REGISTRATION FALLING BY MORE
THAN 120,000 OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS.
THAT MEANS 1.6 MILLION DEMOCRATS
WILL BE REPRESENTED BY TWO
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS.
WHILE 1.9 MILLION REPUBLICANS
WILL DIVVY UP THE REMAINING 13.
THAT'S DEMOCRACY IN NAME ONLY.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR, DEMOCRATS DO
THIS AS WELL.
IN ILLINOIS, THE DEMOCRATIC
STATE LEGISLATURE SET TO
ELIMINATE TWO CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICAN SEATS AND ADDING ONE
DEMOCRATIC.
IN MARYLAND, DEMOCRATS ARE
LOOKING TO GET RID OF ITS SOLE
REPUBLICAN.
IN NEW YORK, AN INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION FAILED
TO FIND CONSENSUS SO THEY'RE
LOOKING TO REDUCE REPUBLICAN
REPRESENTATION.
HERE IS THE THING.
REPUBLICANS HAVE COMPLETE
CONTROL OVER REDISTRICTING IN 20
STATES.
DEMOCRATS IN ONLY 10.
THAT GIVES THE PARTY OF TRUMP
CONTROL OVER 187 HOUSE DISTRICTS
WHILE TO CUT DEMOCRATS HAVE 75.
THIS IS A PARTISAN ARMS RACE.
AND THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE IS
WHAT SUFFERS.
BUT THE FIX IS IN, IT IS NOT YET
INEVITABLE.
THERE WILL BE LAWSUITS SAYING
MAPS VIOLATE THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT.
EIGHT STATES WITH INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSIONS AND
EVEN PROPOSALS TO BRING BACK
PAST REMEDIES LIKE MULTIMEMBER
DISTRICTS WHICH ILLINOIS HAD
UNTIL 1982.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE FIGHT IS ON
RIGHT NOW TO DETERMINE THE FACE
OF CONGRESS FOR THE NEXT DECADE.
AND IT IS NOTHING LESS THAN AN
ATTEMPT TO UNDER